of course there's tactics and all that
but if you get bogged down in those
details you'll never take action
that's why it's start messy that's why
ready is a lie
that's why you punch fear in the face
and you press record that's why your
first videos are your worst videos
when it comes to making your best videos
yet there's actually
five things that are holding you back
and in this
episode we are going right at it this is
probably my
favorite episode so far on the think
media podcast
because we are crushing all the excuses
my name is heather torres and you're
listening to the think
media podcast the number one podcast to
help you grow your influence on youtube
and then turn that influence into a high
impact and high
profit online business and today is a
no miss episode you're going to want to
make sure that you listen to the
entire thing because sean is bringing
the fire i don't want to wait too long
so let's jump into the featured content
and then talk about it afterwards
[Music]
what's up and welcome back to the think
media podcast sean cannell here and i'm
super fired up for this episode but i
need to warn you
you got to buckle your seatbelt because
i hope that sometimes you get great
tactics on this podcast at other times
you get encouragement on this podcast
but today you're going to probably get a
little called
out on this podcast because there's five
things that i
see that hurt youtube creators
success i see these five things that
hurt entrepreneurs success and hold them
back and because
i'm obsessed with helping you win
i can't be silent about these
things and so know that this is coming
in a spirit of love
but sometimes you might need to hear a
little
tough love and these are deadly traps
that keep people from growing on
youtube and i've got five of them let's
get right into it number one
complaining you need to stop complaining
like complaining is a hindrance to you
and i see
so many creators spend so much
energy complaining listen complaining
is not a strategy it is not helping you
to just talk about how hard things are
how bad things are there's maybe a time
where you
vent to your friends but even that
energy
that's not helping you grow your channel
because think about it you need to be
creating
not complaining you'd be surprised how
many people will spend time in discord
on clubhouse in the comments in emails
even on talk with think or whatever
again just talking about how hard things
are and how bad their situation is
and i'm not trying to come with a lack
of empathy today but i'm here to tell
you that complaining is a hindrance
you can either be creating or
complaining
you can't do both and so many people get
held
back by complaining not only that
complaining is a turn off if you ever
want to bring something build something
of significance
we never follow leaders that just
complain all the time
we follow people who look for solutions
don't just
amplify and identify the problems
and when you're complaining you are
actually making sometimes small issues
bigger
as opposed to thinking about the
possibilities not
the problems i want to encourage you if
you want to trigger
growth and get unstuck challenge
yourself
try to not complain this week shoot
that's a long time
try to just go a day without complaining
and focusing on the possibilities and i
believe you will trigger
growth and escape the deadly trap of
complaining the second one is over
consuming
yeah yeah while you're listening to the
think media podcast
i'm like telling you to stop listening
to content you know maybe finish these
five tips
and then get to work but one trap that
gets a lot of youtube creators stuck in
is you've you keep watching videos on
youtube you spend all these hours on
clubhouse rooms listening to people talk
you're watching all this content you're
watching this person that person you're
over
consuming and you're not creating the
videos that you need to create
if you want to know one of the major
secrets
to succeeding on youtube here's what it
is you have to actually
post videos on youtube yeah
i mean it's it's crazy like i mean i
know that you come here for the advanced
stuff there you go
if you want to succeed on youtube post
videos on youtube but if you're
consuming all the time
then you are not posting if you're
consuming all the time then you're not
creating i want to
challenge you to create more than you
consume
is there a time to learn of course
lifelong leaders are lifelong learners
i consume content all the time like i
just like you probably i know that it's
smart to be smart
and to get wisdom and to learn and to
sharpen the acts and to learn from
others and even at times to study the
competition
but here's the test friend are you over
consuming
have you been watching way too much
youtube or did you just get distracted
and said forget youtube i'm just i've
just been on a disney plus
hbo max amazon prime hulu binge i've
just been
jumping between the four i've been all
over the place and if you
stop and reduce your level of
consumption and focus that energy now
you're not complaining
and now you're creating even more the
momentum that you're gonna get on
youtube
is after you post your next best video
the growth you're gonna get on youtube
is on the other side of you posting your
next best video
stop the over consumption and amp up
your creation number three is excuses
excuses excuses are a deadly trap
that keep you stuck listen you can
always
find an excuse you can find a reason too
you can either find a reason or you can
find an excuse you don't want to be
known
as somebody who's like amazing at coming
up with excuses you know what i mean
like
like what what's like their greatest
skill like they're just phenomenal
at coming up with excuses like no noble
person was ever encouraged in that way
it is not a skill set you might have
that skill set
your kids probably have that skill set
man they're so remarkable coming up with
excuses benjamin franklin put it this
way he that is good at making excuses
is seldom good for anything else you can
either have excuses
or you can have results you can't have
both george washington put it this way
99
of failures come from people who have
the habit of making
excuses this is all an energy game
you can give your energy to complaining
you could give your energy to watching
what everybody else is doing and
comparing yourself and looking at what
everybody else is doing and watching and
over consuming
and you can give your energy to excuses
there's something about
sitting down if you find audit your
conversation audit the
vibe of the people you hang out with
audit the vibe of the clubhouse rooms
you're in
audit the vibe of the way in your energy
and comments
if you're investing all of this energy
in excuses then you're not investing
energy in
creating are you getting enough tough
love yet i want you to hear my heart
i want you to win and i just see way too
many people get
held back by just making excuses
if you really want to do it you just do
it
there's no excuses if you really want to
do it just do it
in fact don't talk about it talk less do
more one of the pet peeves as a rabbit
trail that's kind of on the same theme
is people who declare what they're about
to do
a lot of people who are just you know
i'm gonna start a youtube channel i'm
going to
launch a new project why don't you go
launch the project
instead of saying you're going to launch
the project and then
why haven't you uploaded lately ah you
know i don't know man
the economy like what does the economy
have to do with you uploading or not
like if you've got the tools and the
internet connections to
ah you know i was busy you know well of
course you were
who's not busy ah you know i just kind
of was tired of course you're freaking
tired dude everyone's tired like
life is hard uh well you know i got in a
fight with my wife
every couple fights you got to figure
out how to get past ah
well i don't know the competition is
other people that uh
they're posting videos yeah but you're
never gonna be able to break through
unless you start posting videos ah
well someone already started i'm
thinking about starting my channel but
then i just saw someone else and
uh you know you're making excuses stop
the madness and stop the excuses
if you want momentum excuses are going
to drag you down and slow you
down which brings us to number four
overthinking yeah overthinking
five deadly traps that keep you from
growing on youtube
overthinking man how real is this
so many people we get to coach and
encourage
and and connect with their their
overthinking is like their superpower
like it's like well what if you know
should i name my channel
this this or this and should i start on
a tuesday or a wednesday
or a friday should i should i upload my
five videos in the first week
and then one video a week should i and
i'm like dude i don't
who who cares just post a video
yeah but like should the video be five
minutes eight minutes 10 minutes or 12
minutes
dude you're freaking overthinking of
course there's tactics and all that
but if you get bogged down in those
details you'll never take action
that's why it's start messy that's why
ready is a lie
that's why you punch fear in the face
and you press record that's why your
first videos are your worst videos
yeah but like should my first video be
about me or should it be like a product
review
or should my first do i do them all
do what please do something yeah but
like what should i
you know it's kind of like summer now
maybe i should like wait until it's back
to school to post my no
do do both take freaking action
stop pondering and start
posting okay stop
procrastinating and start
posting you know my friend john acuff
has a new book highly recommended it's
called soundtracks it's about
overthinking and of course we always
drop resources in the show notes
overthinking isn't a personality trait
it's the sneakiest form of fear
yeah really what overthinking is is fear
this is from john a cuff's book it
steals time it steals creativity
and it steals your goals it's a deadly
trap
you your fear is manifesting in i don't
know like
it's like raining today maybe i
shouldn't shoot a video you're shooting
the video inside
yeah i don't i i just like saw that
maybe the stock market
dude who cares about the stock market
post your
video yeah but like i'm not very good on
camera either was i
so post some bad videos to get to your
good videos yeah but like
what if a meteorite that i saw in joe
rogan
like actually hits the planet in two
months from now
because if it does then the two months
of me posting youtube videos won't
matter because
mankind will be extinct from the
meteorite that might hit the
well of course okay then it won't really
matter will it
so you might as well just post videos
anyways if you have any ambition at all
to start youtube then freaking start
youtube and stop over
thinking are you getting anything out of
this video yet
we got one more but these are reasons
you stay stuck
and i hope that you hear my heart i want
you to win complaining is not helping
you
over consuming is not helping you
excuses are not
helping you and over thinking is not
helping you the fifth one
and this is one of the most insidious
enemies of all this is a deadly trap
is the trap of comparison
man comparison is the thief of joy
right don't compare your beginning
john akaff said this don't compare your
beginning to somebody else's middle
a huge reason why we stay stuck and even
over consuming
is we get into this loop let me know if
you can relate you start watching some
youtube videos because you're doing
reconnaissance right you're overthinking
you're also procrastinating
and you're making excuses to post
because i need to learn more still i
need to study my niche more
i need to like look at what's happening
okay so now you're watching but now
you're starting to compare
now you're like oh my gosh she's just
like such a better talker than me talker
like he he just seems to know his stuff
better than me
shoot man i found like 10 personal
finance channels why should i start a
personal finance chat
like so now you're comparing yourself to
everybody else so you're in this loop of
over
consumption and you're comparing
yourself to everything you're consuming
further stealing your own confidence
from actually posting your own video
so then you're like man i need to get
off youtube so you get on instagram
and start swiping and comparing yourself
now you're comparing your life you're
comparing your kids
you're comparing your situation you're
comparing yourself to people who are
starting people who haven't started you
compare
you're making up scenarios because you
don't even really know what's going on
in anybody's life
you don't know what's going on in your
youtube channel you don't know why
they're getting views
why they go viral maybe they had a bunch
of money and someone actually paid for
ads on their video
you're making up scenarios to reduce
yourself and to put others on pedestals
and in this loop of comparison
which is robbing your energy and keeping
you stuck
it's a deadly trap the goal here is to
create
and to not compare and if you see a
theme of what is the response
to any of these is to not complain
but to create instead into post videos
to not
over consume content but to make sure
you create more than you consume
to not sit around and architect your
excuses
but to architect your next piece of
content in your next youtube video
and to post that instead to not
overthink
and stay planning your video forever but
to stop researching at some point
and then to actually press record and
create the video
and then not spend time wandering
through every single social media
channel just comparing yourself to
everybody else
but turning off the comparison and
turning up the creation
and posting the video i hope that
after this episode you are motivated to
kill these deadly traps and these
enemies
and to just keep posting videos to put
blinders on
to put your head down and to say i'm
making a decision today
that i'm not going to let these energy
vampires
drain my emotional strength drain my
confidence
drain my feelings of myself that i need
the confidence and the bravery
and the energy i need to even create
content i'm not gonna give it away any
longer and i'm going to
stay focused and create the content that
i need
to create never forget that your energy
is limited you only have so much and you
got to give some to yourself you got to
give some
to your family you got to give some to
your kids you got to give some to your
studies
you got to give somebody your job man
the energy you have left over
to create the youtube content you need
to create and to build your youtube
empire
man it's limited so you got to protect
it and if you're wasting it
it's no surprise that you have no energy
left
after at the end of everything else and
it's not because your kids
and it's not because of your family
although those are probably influencing
it
no it's because on top of all that
you're giving your energy to
overconsumption excuses over thinking
comparison and complaining
so channel it instead into creating your
next
best video and i promise you friend
you're going to experience a whole
nother level of momentum on youtube
when you get away from these deadly
traps and you go
all in on creating your next
best video
all right coach sean was here and i hope
that that was
something that encouraged you even
though it was hard to hear sometimes
you know for me specifically it's things
like comparison that hold me back but
i am for sure an over thinker
i want to think through the entire
process i want to overthink the video
that i'm doing
and i just have to punch fear in the
face and press
record i was even challenged this week
where sean said heather you should just
make this video
and instantly when he said that i had 10
things in my head
as to what i needed to think about or
what i needed to do
before that video could be this magic
word
perfect and perfectionism is holding us
back the overthinking of these videos is
holding us back
from creating great work so a lot of
times most of the time
hear me friend you just need to do the
work you just gotta get the videos out
because you need to be creating a lot of
content
to become great at creating content even
us doing this podcast here
me actually doing the intro to this
podcast i messed up several times
but it's just knowing that you can just
get back up and get going again so i
hope that this
uh episode brought you value and if you
liked this episode please make sure to
subscribe here to the podcast
as well as leave a comment if you're
listening on youtube and
rate and review us over on apple itunes
this helps us get this podcast
in front of more purpose-driven content
creators just
like you we want to help the entire
youtube
world learn how to do youtube right all
the people who want to get on youtube
we want to help them do that the right
way so if you want to share this with a
friend that would be helpful
but i would love for you to leave some
leave a comment over on apple itunes
rate and review
and you might be featured on a future
episode
today's episode feature comes from
streetsoldiers.com
sean and his team are very genuine and
care
you help people grow their business and
their audience highly
recommend well thank you so much for
leaving that comment and i hope to read
your comment on a future
upcoming episode also if you've not
taken
our think master class make sure you
sign up at think thinkmasterclass.com
where you can learn the three secrets to
success on youtube
and learn how to do youtube right and at
the end of that class you'll have an
opportunity to join us on a deeper level
inside of our video ranking academy the
number one community for
youtubers and online content creators so
make sure you check out that free class
and get signed up for video ranking
academy if it's right for you
well thank you so much for being a part
of our think community
thank you for listening to this podcast
and i cannot wait to see you in a future
[Music]
episode
you